we begin with breaking news coming out
of Southern Lebanon where a highlevel
Hezbollah field commander has been
assassinated in an Israeli strike Wham
Al known as jaad was the group's
director of military operations he was
killed when the car that he was
traveling in was targeted let's speak to
Imran Khan who's monitoring uh this from
iel El saki in southern Lebanon Imran
what seems to be or what seems to have
been the circumstances around this
incident
well the incident actually began around
11:00 a.m. local when Israeli drone
strike hit a car traveling in the kbat
Saleem Village about 10 km inside
Lebanese uh territory uh that car was
carrying as you say a hisbah commander
hisbah have actually confirmed that it
was Wasim alil also known as Jad who was
also from that village now he's the
highest ranking officer that that has
been killed uh since hostilities began
on October the 8th the Israelis say this
was the man that was responsible for
Rocket attacks against a key Israeli
military installation uh in the Galilee
uh this was an attack that came in
response to the killing of senior Hamas
leader Salah Al Ari who was killed in
Beirut last week so this is a going to
be a setback for Hezbollah it's going to
be something that they will feel but
it's not going to stop them uh the way
Hezbollah is set up is there are people
who are always ready to replace
commanders soldiers Fighters that have
been uh killed in the battlefield so
although it is going to be a very big
blow to his well it's not going to stop
them but this is going to come as
alarming to the International Community
what they're trying to do is keep a
control of this border they want Israel
and hisbah to keep this contained and
for it not to spill out into an allout
war that will involve Lebanon uh
completely there's been shuttle
diplomacy coming uh from people like
France from the US indeed the German
foreign minister is due to arrive in
country uh tomorrow we're also hearing
that the US Special Envoy Amos Hawkin is
due to arrive in bayout next week as
well uh to try and make sure that both
sides don't over escalate but something
like this is going to Warrant a response
from Hezbollah and they've always
maintained as have is
that if either Israel or Hamas sorry
Israel or Hezbollah want a war then
they'll get one and that's very
dangerous language and we're in very
dangerous times just in the last few
moments heard air strikes there's been
shelling we've also heard Rockets leave
from uh where near where I am uh across
into Israel so tensions very much still
live Iman KH Forest there in southern
Lebanon thank you